back in the studio everybody here we are
um yeah
um we're all here we're all here all
here uh good to see Glenn so there's one
thing that's a little bit different I'd
like to just address it right away rob
you rob you shaved your head
I I have
I had a vivid dream last night
that I had shaved my own head and it's
very surreal that you walked in here
with a shaved head this morning it could
be that we have an E.T Elliot it's a
psychic connection yes yes I felt the
Shaving of your head and it went into my
subconscious
haunted me in my dream actually I liked
how it looked in my dream did I feel the
three beers you had at like uh eight
o'clock you might have felt them and I
think it was more than three well at
eight it was about three
deep
uh yeah it's probably about right oh
okay yeah hey guys
um
do you want to stick your dicks in my
mouth
not yet no I mean maybe later why would
you say that
the thought
um I I did shave my head I did have my
my head shaved for uh I'm doing a just
like Glenn I'm doing a hair bit for a
for a role in the in the show that I do
for apple called Mr Quest and we needed
a request Mr Quest
you were doing a Mr Quest thing you
shaved your head for it well yes I
needed a new look but also if I'm being
dead honest I just wanted to mix it up I
just wanted to mix it up sometimes I
like to do impulsive things and yeah and
shave my head yeah man I get summer's
coming you know like uh feels starting
to feel warm yeah and I was like look at
these like that's I'm wearing like a
nuke style shoe which I don't think you
I've seen you wear versions of this same
exact shoe yeah yeah which like uh yeah
like during a press thing sure someone
was like Hey you look a little sharper
in uh all white shoe like well I had
some I had somebody dressed me for some
some silly event and she said she's a
very good stylist she said no more of
these Air Jordans you're wearing I said
why she said because you're not a 14
year old child oh she said you're going
to look you're going to look like a guy
who I like that I came in here and you
don't know if I'm going to do a podcast
or go bowling you know at any given
moment or a rally some sort of rally
yeah that's a problem
yeah the white sneaker tells me that
you're not going to go to a rally which
is nice since I feel safer the white
sneaker tells me that you think you
think that you're you're pretty soon
you're going to be headed up to meet
whoever you believe you're God to be
yeah oh that's right well if I had like
a nice little Pete like a hair piece in
the back that's what I was thinking I
saw a dad at my school uh at graduation
who had a little like had a had shaved
his head but kept a little rat tail and
dyed it bright yellow okay and he had a
big beard going too and it yeah it
looked pretty fantastic I gotta say I
couldn't do it myself but I mean I could
but I would need an excuse like it's for
a part yeah now what was his it's just
he he was just going for a little
Krishna because that's the hurricane now
he's like an awesome chef and he's just
like yeah [ __ ] around yeah I get it
mixing it up it was cool
uh I also saw Dwayne The Rock Johnson oh
yeah how's Dwayne doing he looks [ __ ]
great man really holy [ __ ] yeah muscular
huh I feel like he works out or
something
um
I had a thing that happened to me this
morning so I went to uh make a piece of
toast you guys remember carbs yeah yeah
yeah yeah you guys you guys probably
haven't had a long time but I was gonna
have a piece of toast and I went I I
pulled it out like put it between my
teeth and I was tying up the bag and
then the smell of the bread was like
aluminum so like something in the bag
was moldy and I got freaked out that I
had the moldy bread in my mouth on my
lips and my tongue so I grabbed some
whiskey yeah yeah and I swelled it
around yeah just yeah that's the move
just to care like vodka something to
kill kill the bad guys wait let me talk
about whiskey for a second because so
Todd Biermann who is one of our
directors on on sunny and also Mythic
Quest I was just in a wedding at a
wedding with him in Texas and Texas it's
a free-for-all in Texas of course which
is what's great about Texas and we were
at this hotel Texas sure and we were
having a blast and we were packed full
of people all over all over this uh
Hotel all over the city really and Todd
and I then traveled back together and we
were sitting next to each other for a
good four hours and those airplanes are
loud so we're screaming into each
other's faces having a conversation on
the way home we also happen to be
drinking bourbon next to you guys I love
sitting next to Guys Like You on an
airplane well no it's just screaming
across the aisle at each other no no we
were sitting right next to each other
and what I mean by screaming is just
that the plane was loud and we were
having a conversation but the point I'm
trying to make is that we were very
close when we were having the
conversation and then um Todd came home
and he popped hot for covet not Todd
he's supposed to be directing
um the uh the episode of Myth Quest and
that's why Meg's not here because she
had to step in and direct the episode I
couldn't because I'm not allowed to set
because I was in proximity to somebody
who tested positive however I've since
taken three tests and I'm negative and
I'm I'm actually going to um credit the
bourbon with that now I don't have the
science to to back this up also could
the bourbon have killed killed the covet
on the way hey we just don't know
there's so much we just don't know you
know
um if that was true I feel like the
island of Ireland would have never
gotten coveted but it did so probably
not did I though I don't know I don't
know maybe are you are you believing the
mainstream media these days Charlie
because
oh no no no no no no no no no no no I
get all my information from my own
subconscious there
[Music]
Glenn you're looking great oh thanks
yeah I um I guess I don't know I felt
like wearing a collared shirt today and
uh making my mouth so that you guys
could stick your dick in it whenever you
wanted I mean that's just that just like
you know when you wake up and you have a
certain feeling you're like what am I
going to wear today what do I what do I
want to project you know what I mean
what do I want the world to see me as so
who you know do I want to you know where
do I want a dick to go you know what I
mean and then you just sort of act
accordingly you dress accordingly and
you you formulate your mouth a certain
way because you want to you know be you
either invite that sort of thing or or
you don't yeah yeah that was the
thinking there but um it is great to
finally be back in the studio with you
guys I will say I I uh I missed seeing
you in person good I agree I'm so happy
to be back in this studio I guess for
the for the for the non-creeps for the
listeners
we should say that Glenn is back in the
studio but in a very specific way
his body is held uh very still his mouth
is in uh penis receiving shape
oh it doesn't have to be a penis it
could be receiving any anything really
oh sure yeah yeah yeah anything around
anything in there put a golf ball in
there because sure kind of funny sure
absolutely yeah put a ping pong ball in
there you have a you have like a rubbery
look to your skin
um but not not too robbery you know I
think in a dark room you'd really give
someone a start why do they call it what
it feels like you walk around you walk
around L.A and um you know you you start
to
I never saw myself as someone who would
get you know the amount of plastic
surgery that I've had uh look at that
look at that work you know what I mean
it's like I'm now at a point where I've
botoxed so much that I can't even move
well you've taken plastic surgery to a
new level and replaced your body with
plastic completely yes yeah Plastics
durable and uh it lasts forever
um you know as as we can see by uh by
the oceans
have you guys seen top gun Maverick oh
yeah it's [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah I
can't wait because you know what you
know it's an entertaining uh planes
going 700 miles an hour and then blowing
things up uh do you notice how they
didn't name any enemy they were saying
very cool the bad guy very clear the bad
guy has is in enriching their uranium
serious so that's literally exactly like
our last Lethal Weapon episode where
we're like don't name us don't name
don't name a surgical Market world don't
name a certain do not upset a certain
marker don't set any markets the bad guy
is enriching their uranium we have to
get in there and so uh I kept leaning
over to Mary Elizabeth during the big
action sequences being like they're in
Canada
look at all the snow the bad guys Canada
what were they implying was it Russia
why it's hard to say they or they really
were being not as good because that
topography's in China that topography's
in I mean there's North Korea I feel
like there was Desert
yeah and you couldn't see I think any of
the all the all the guys in the in the
in the opposing airplanes you couldn't
see they had masks they did have sort of
very uh Cold War kind of decals on their
planes you know um yeah but I think they
were suggesting that those were bought
those that those were relics bought by
the former Soviet Union I think they
covered every base are you guys [ __ ]
kidding me it's literally exactly what
we did on in the Lethal Weapon yeah and
they were like we just we were gonna
make this as vague as and it's still a
good movie
not only is it good it's the same exact
movie that they made the first time the
the same exactly well and it's but and
they leaned all the way into it Tom
Cruise looks fantastic he does he does
Tom Cruise is a different I don't know
that he's human right he's maybe he's
not here yeah who knows what the heck
he's doing but like but it's working
yeah I don't look at his face and and
think wow he's got as much plastic
surgery as Glenn has yeah look at all
that work um but you know what is also
speaking of where where to put penises
uh bums are making a mess all over the
city wow and uh okay I was not when we
when I knew that this was the episode we
were going to be talking about and I and
I popped it on last night and again just
to remind everybody I have not seen
these episodes in well over a decade
yeah I remember I remember distinctly
disliking this episode at the time
thinking we went too far with the
costumes we went too far with the
silliness with the parody and
um it was just getting a little bit off
the rails and I watched it and thought
it was one of the funniest episodes
we've ever done I absolutely agree yeah
I watched that [ __ ] thing and I was
like oh my God there's a freedom
to the storytelling which that we have
which is to to be like basically
whatever we think is going to be [ __ ]
funny works right so whether it's the
cat who by the way it was so hot in that
cop car in Philly the cat's mouth is
wide open because it's panting out of
its mouth something I've never seen a
tattoo it's like it's like heavy
breathing yeah as I recall and you guys
correct me if I'm wrong because I was
thinking about this too
I think we shot the interior cop car
stuff in Downtown LA and then we shot
the exterior cop car stuff in Philly so
I believe we actually shot that in
Downtown LA but it was I do know it was
the dead Of Summer Wherever it was and
you are right cats don't generally pant
unless they are just like Beyond hot so
you can if you look you can see we're
all sweating like we're all very you
know we're glistening with sweat in that
in that scene you know what you're
probably right that probably was
downtown L.A because we would not have
brought the cat and the cat trainer to
Philly right right that would have been
like that's right an extra cost that
wasn't necessary right we would have
been like well I mean we could have we
can we can shoot all the cat stuff in
L.A I do remember how careful we were
with that cat and and there's obviously
there's there's all sorts of regulations
about how you are to be treating animals
on set and they're there for a good
reason and we were very very careful
about that that Health that the cat's
safety so much so that I remember the
joke at the end was that he gets agent
Jack Bauer gets blown to safety from the
car yeah and we couldn't even we just
wanted to just not even throw the cat
just lightly places just have him drop
from the top of the frame down exactly a
cattle jump off a bookshelf and land on
its feet no problem so like yes so we're
like Can it can it drop from above lens
height in fact how about we don't drop
it we just let the cat stand on an
elevated platform no higher than a table
and we'll just hold a treat and he can
just jump jumps down again one thing but
they were very it was I remember being
very strict and if you look at that shot
he he barely Falls from it just looks
like he's placed there you know I was so
beyond frustrated when we were shooting
that because I own cats my whole life
and Chuck myself
I [ __ ] I choose to throw cats across
the room the cat loves being chucked
around yeah Charlie chops cats chopcat
Chuck well no but a cat a cat a cat a
cat can jump a cat could jump from a
two-story a window and be fine yeah you
know what I mean and I felt like I was
like these are you guys are cat trainers
and I feel like you don't understand
cats at all you don't you don't get it
you don't understand what they're
capable of and I it was just so
frustrating because but we did specific
we didn't actually want like what you
were talking about Rob because if a cat
jumps on its own it's going to land on
its front feet first and then it's gonna
plop down on its we wanted it to land on
all four feet at the same time so we
literally just said we put the camera as
low as we could possibly put it we just
were like let it just drop it from not
even a foot I mean it was like it was
like a foot and a half the way that you
would place a cat almost like the way
that you would move your cat from say a
table you didn't want him on you just
wanted to put them on the ground the way
that everybody puts drops their cat they
don't throw it to the ground like a
baseball but they also don't just
carefully Place him down we were being
very respectful to to the animal I
wasn't now I will say watching it I'd
forgotten about that moment and when I
saw like the cat with like the smoke
coming off of it or whatever which we
must add and post I don't know how we
did that but like uh uh I gotta chuckle
out it worked yeah although I I remember
I was more watching that to be like oh
what was the original joke I bet
that I was trying to push for that we
just blow the cat up
and then we were like ah or the network
was like ah it's too much I can't
remember but that sounds right to me
yeah my instinct was like no I I think
right from the beginning we were like
you know we're like this cat can survive
this cat can survive anything it can
survive anything
but I feel yeah I do believe that
Charlie's sense of humor at least at one
point would have said well isn't it more
isn't it funnier that we're setting up
that he that he will survive anything
and then the finals
he won't survive a car blowing up yeah
yeah I could see that the guy that we
buy the cat from the expression he gives
when we say when you say and throw in
that cat
it's the oddest look but he's like you
know you're like what like is the you
know is the cop car for sale I was like
yeah everything's for sale I'm like
we'll take it and throw in that cat and
he gives like this little like happy
look that he's finally selling the cat
as a man well let's start from the
beginning because the opening scene has
Danny's good friend Tracy Tracy uh who's
been in a lot of movies uh most famously
I famously I think Batman Batman is like
the Joker's henchman yeah uh Bob
character's name is Bob is that right
yeah and Tracy's been in a million
movies for Repo Man and you know he's
just been around forever yeah and he was
Danny's friend yep and he wanted to
be on the show and we said you want to
be a masturbating bum he's like sure
who gets beat up and um one of those I
remember one of those uh trash cans that
Caitlyn is hitting him with yeah that
was an actual trash can and they had not
either the either they had not switched
it out or she grabbed the wrong she
grabbed the wrong one was a rubber and
one was a metal lid and she picks up the
metal in and then bam yeah
whoa whoa what kind of show is this yeah
yeah this is a student film yeah yeah
hey can we give me a stunt guy first
yeah exactly well no I what no what
happened was they did have a stunt guy
if you watch the episode it's a stunt
guy it's a stunt guy and he's getting
hit with a rubber thing and then when
they switched it out because they were I
think um you know Jerry wanted to get
one shot so that you could actually see
uh Tracy's face and so it was a
different setup and and I believe uh you
know they just forgot to place the prop
in the right place or maybe Caitlyn
grabbed the wrong trash can land but
yeah she bashes him with an actual trash
it's in it's in the it's in the outtakes
I think it's in the the seasons of the
bloopers and I'm where this is the
episode where I'm wearing a t-shirt as
an homage to Jerry who was our director
oh yeah and that t-shirt
remember what it says something dick
knows
what are you looking at but the best
part of it is that there's no question
mark at the end so it's a question right
but it's more of a statement what are
you looking at yes and that's that's
taken verbatim from the movie Teen Wolf
that is right uh Jerry Levine's
character Styles uh wears a t-shirt
albeit not sleeveless I don't think
um in the movie Teen Wolf that says what
are you looking at dick knows and uh
yeah so that was a a tribute to our
director yeah I remember finding Teen
Wolf disturbing as a kid like seeing the
trailers and be like ah I feel yeah I'm
uncomfortable with the hairy face well
why is it that somebody turns into a
wolf and they can play basketball I
don't better than everybody because I
don't know that wolves are you know
basketball I would not have a theory
about that no okay
about why a wolf would be a basketball
no here's here's well you're not wrong
first of all but if I were to have to
justify it what I would say is and maybe
if I was in those you know production
meetings back in the 80s having that
conversation and snorting line after
line of cocaine as we were discussing
these ideas I would have said I think I
would have said well it's not that the
wolf it's not that a wolf is better at
basketball it's that he would be that
good at basketball if he had the
physical prowess of a wolf in other
words Michael J Fox's character is
actually a good basketball player he's
just small and weak if he had the body
of a werewolf he would be able to do all
of the things
right he has the Mega Strength of a fly
yeah you could also melt your food by
vomiting on it yeah I believe it also
made him very popular with the ladies
now that was an odd one that was that
yeah it's confusing that's confusing
yeah that's confusing no but hairy men
everywhere hairy men everywhere watched
that movie and they were like see you
know and the women were still like I
don't see
um but guys I think we've talked about
this before on the podcast
yes this is the problem we asked Meg
she's not even here we ask her to cut it
again I've mentioned this on the podcast
I know but she doesn't cut it and now
that then we look like [ __ ] because
we've already had this conversation but
we spend so much time together we don't
know what we're talking I don't know we
don't know well let's get back to the
episode one thing I really loved was the
pacing oh yeah I love the pacing of the
episode we move so quickly from scene to
scene to Scene It feels very economical
it's it's it's light right like all we
we buy a cop car and we want to drive
around in it and get free hot dogs uh
we all just start taking it too far in
our own specific ways
uh you and Caitlin want to clean up the
streets because we have someone
masturbating in a rally and that's it's
as simple as that it's as simple as that
um
the the joke of the cops dropping you
off in the bad neighborhood and then The
Gunshot and everyone's scattering
is great like and then the the the
taking it the next level when you say
and this I do feel like we've talked
about on the show but like about like
hey this guy doesn't we got to get out
of here let's find someone who looks
safe we very clearly say we are in an
African-American neighborhood which is a
bad neighborhood from this these
characters point of view and then and
then you're watching oh wow so you're
not like a lower socio economic
African-American neighborhood yeah
that's what I said but that's what sets
up the joke that's coming yeah that's
what says of the joke which is that then
you walk right past the nice looking man
and you go to your dad is playing the
crackhead yeah and he pulls a gun on you
and we suggest that these characters
believe that this is a bad neighborhood
simply because if they're that is a
great way to do a joke about racism
about these characters racist
perspective on where they are
um yes and and that is my actual dad and
that's where actually was playing the
crackhead I guess we used to cry we
don't know if he's a crackhead maybe
he's a meth head he's clearly on drugs
of some sort yeah and he points the gun
up at us yeah that's my dad and gives
you a big uh big disgusting
which I gotta say was uh you know I his
performance in that moment is pretty
terrific did he do a little bit of
acting when he was younger did he do
some plays or something well I don't say
he did or he played Joseph in the uh
yeah Joseph and the Amazing technical
Dreamcoat no just like some kind of like
church thing oh yeah probably right
probably yeah
yeah no I don't I don't think he had any
back he doesn't have any background and
he's just a he was he was game there
were a lot of actors in this episode
that were from Philly yeah like the kid
that we kind of mug
um for jaywalking was like a Philly
actor and then the hot dog guy yep or
the or maybe from New York that came in
but but either way they were East
Coasters that's for sure they might have
been from New York but I feel like we
did like Philly casting sessions back in
the day we did but Glenn's cop character
is so great let's copying those glasses
so great that was yeah that was fun Jam
everybody up like eight years later and
yeah getting jammed up that was taken
straight from NYPD Blue I was obsessed
with NYPD Blue yeah and all they talked
about was getting jammed up and jamming
each other up and I don't want to jam
you up and that just felt like so
um a few years later they did a movie
called Let's Be Cops the Jake Johnson
movie Yes with Damon Wayans Jr and they
essentially just found a cop car started
driving around and started getting
treated like cops so then they decided
that they were going to act like cops
and get all the stuff and I remember
when the movie came out and we all said
this is we did this episode we did this
exact episode and now they're making a
movie out of it and it was independent
movie but it I think it made some money
for them and yeah it did pretty well and
everybody's you're stupid you're stupid
well then I ran into Jake a few years in
fact I worked with Jake a few years ago
and I brought that up to him and he goes
oh yeah I think the writer saw that
episode and thought it was funny they
should just make a whole movie about it
it might not be too late to sue shall we
it might not be too late to sue yeah
yeah let's get litigious should we get
litigious I would I would get litigious
I would be afraid we would be opening
ourselves up
um to those same lawsuits I forget I
mean I literally just said we stole the
jamming the jamming stuff up from them I
mean everybody steals that's the thing
that's the thing we're all stealing
[Music]
all right gang Charlie forgot to catch
this stack of checks on his keyboard and
now he's lost a small fortune and you
know here's the thing I just haven't
been feeling like walking to the bank
for the last like 10 years or so did you
know that there's such a thing as Mobile
deposit now yeah yeah but that's a lot
of work too and then there's an app
there's passwords you know
it's too much but today you can help
Charlie recoup his keyboard money with
this ad from our friends at
Shopify Shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once observed for big
businesses so now any type of business
can sell goods and services digitally
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed including
startups upstarts and established
businesses look scaling your business is
a journey of endless possibility but I
personally love how Shopify has the
tools and resources to make it easy for
any business to succeed from down the
street to around the globe whoa it's
more than a store okay Shopify grows
with you you can gain insights as you
grow with detailed reporting of
conversion rates profit margins and
Beyond the this is possibility
and it's powered by Shopify so go to
shopify.com Sunny all lowercase for a
free 14-day trial and get full access to
shopify's entire Suite of features grow
your business with Shopify today guys go
ahead and grow your business for Shopify
today go to shopify.com sunny right now
that's shopify.com
let's talk about the music of this
episode the music of this episode makes
this episode work and
it was just another case of us doing
something very Broad and then and then
the music leaning into it all the way in
the music we get in the editing room and
we're using our usual like
and it's not you know cutting together
right it doesn't feel right and we
started digging around we find this sort
of like 70 serpico-esque like cop music
and suddenly it's just stitching the
whole thing together in a great way and
I I do miss the I watched that episode
and there's an innocence to what we're
doing that I really miss and by
innocence I just mean like a lack of
experience in a good way which is that
we don't know what the show is yet we
don't know what works or what doesn't
work and we're kind of like well maybe
this will be funny and then it is which
is good
it played pretty well played pretty well
I
I kind of want to put my finger inside
Glenn that's I was just thinking the
same thing you were telling that story
and you're looking at it now Glenn I'm
thinking it hasn't moved for however
long we've been talking you wanna put
your thumb in there not my thumb it's
waiting for you I'm waiting for you you
want to put something private in there
no no no I'm looking around for
something to put in there like a cigar
or something that we could but you know
a cigar would be fun
would you like a cigar
ette I don't know that we have access to
it are you getting thirsty at some point
how deep does it go
well
let me just put your thumb in there
I'll take the mic with me here hang on
or I can use his mic yeah you can use
Mike yeah is that hot is that a hot mic
yeah it's hot Mike all right I'm gonna
stick my feet oh wow oh buddy that goes
into your brain that goes all the way
back that's right yeah so that guy oh my
God that sucker is functioning oh it's
God yeah I'm oh yeah
sorry about that Glenn sorry about that
yeah sorry buddy sorry okay that's okay
that's all right I asked for it I'm
asking for it yeah that was very
specifically that was designed for
something oh yeah a couple things about
this episode
um I don't know if you guys recall but
that opening sequence with Tracy
masturbating and us just standing there
watching him was not the original uh
opening sequence of the of the episode
and we completely this Rings about it
this rings a bell what was the original
scene is some of it in the bloopers yeah
there would have had to have been a lot
of dialogue a conversation about what we
were seeing and we probably got to the
edit again there was no no words
necessary yeah so the scene was there
right right so the scene of you guys
running into him but you were probably
saying XYZ and he was making noises and
then we just landed on silence yeah yeah
yeah yeah and and and you know when
Tracy you know kind of looks up at us
and gives us that big smile it's just I
laughed my ass off and I know I was in
for a ride I very much enjoyed that yeah
same I liked every once in a while to
picture some of the episodes that people
that has to have been the first episode
that somebody saw at some point right I
like the idea of somebody sitting down
and saying I heard about this weird show
that my friends are telling me about and
some people hate it and some people love
it I gotta just check this out and
watching that and for the first time and
just being so utterly confused I always
think it's funny when people are like go
to watch our show for the first time and
it must just be like
taking a bottle of vodka just pouring it
down someone's throat and just be like
ah you're gonna you may or may not like
this out somebody but here it comes I
absolutely hate when people who don't
who meet me who say I've heard of your
show from my kids or my family or my
friends but I've never actually seen it
but I want to start can you tell me
which episodes I should start with I
have no answer to that I have no answer
yeah I don't know what's the answer
entry point it's different for everybody
it's different for everybody because
everybody is yeah yeah sometimes I'm
like watch season five just start with
Seasons yes I just watch season five and
go back I don't know that's I I actually
agree with you Charlie I I feel like at
this point you know but again that's
that's with my that's with my
sensibilities now yeah that's right and
at a certain point I probably would have
said season three but I I think now I
would be scared to say season three
because I feel like it's it's a little
too crazy to start with
um and season five I feel like is
really solid I don't know yeah start at
the beginning maybe yeah I mean either
way I feel I feel like though your mouth
would be a metaphor for that experience
as well which is you just got to open up
wide and whatever gets shot you gotta
take take it in and don't fight against
it I mean you can just turn it off yeah
he can't but no he can't he can't he
can't he can he can he was designed that
way yeah he was designed that there's a
great uh one of my favorite lines in the
episode
I'm sorry but if he's truly designed
after Dennis Reynolds his design should
not be about my satisfaction at all so
in in some ways
this doll is getting What It Wants I'm
sorry this but it wasn't designed by me
it was designed by Mac
oh it was designed by Magnus that's true
that's true to replace me if it was a
problem it was an accurate
representation
your pleasure I know you're right if I
had designed it if I had designed it um
it'd be a little razor blade down that
mouth and that would be like well we all
about it it wouldn't be a second Twisted
yeah
yeah I wouldn't be a vessel for someone
else's pleasure no not at all not
administering I'd be administering
pleasure and justice
[Laughter]
often at the same time
um Justice one of the
um one of the best lines in the episode
it makes me laugh so hard and it's such
a throwaway line after we walk in after
the opening title sequence and we're
telling you Charlie and um we're telling
Charlie and and Frank uh you know
there's that there's a masturbating bomb
in the alley and Charlie's like oh yeah
I've seen that guy but the best line is
is uh I think it I don't know if it's me
that I think I come in and I go there's
a bum masturbating in the alley and and
Danny goes Danny goes masturbating bums
are bad for business
as if that's something that needs to be
said like
like he's teaching us a lesson in that
moment as if there could be some
confusion you know as if as if we're
about to have a debate as to whether
that's good for business or not he's
just gonna get like right off the bat
listen guys I need to teach you
something masturbating bums in the alley
are bad for business uh that that [ __ ]
made me laugh
I think for our uh listeners and creeps
who are young aspiring filmmakers uh or
TV makers or whatever what have you uh
tick tockers
um
it's probably nice to know that
I would say
85 percent of the time
what we set out to do doesn't totally
work out right we've written something
and we've shot something we get into the
editing room and
for whatever reason it doesn't work
right and then we have to find okay
uh with this type of music completely
radically changes the episode and makes
it work or oh this scene doesn't work
but let's just have the guy masturbating
in silence and it's it's so interesting
how it is that over and over and over
again for all 15 years you know there's
no sort of blueprint for it every now
and then we walk in and we're like wow
this thing's pretty much tight top to
bottom let's do a couple tweaks and call
it a day but that's super rare well one
thing that I've noticed is that I I now
have the ability to watch a cut of say
Mr Quest or whatever show it might be
and I can watch the cut and pretty much
yeah uh
what's ap what
AP Bio
I've never seen I've never seen that
um I could watch a cut of something also
talking about something he did in school
oh well if you want to set up my way
give me notes on it yeah it's like a
student film
no um anyway I I think we all have this
abilities that you can look at a cut now
and see pretty much see what needs to
change in it and and that's only that
only comes like I could sit in it with
an editor and watch an episode of
something and say okay change this
change that cut this put a musical
transition in here lose that scene
entirely and just try that and then you
come back and it's not 100 but you can
pretty much guess right and the reason
we can guess right is just simply
because we've spent thousands of hours
in editorial and it comes we think in my
mind I forget it it feels like it comes
naturally but it doesn't it's a learned
skill you have to sit in front of and
you now we have everybody has the
editing software on their phones you
just gotta try
is the weird thing too of like
you know you just said I remember
thinking that this episode wasn't our
best and maybe a little too broad and
then you look at it
however many years later decade later
and you're like oh it's actually pretty
good uh
I'm feeling the same right so then
there's that weird side of it too where
like you've done the work you've put it
together you say okay this is the best I
can make this but I know it's not really
the best it could have been but then you
go back and you look at it and you say
oh no it probably is BET is better than
I realized that everyone would have been
you know like uh maybe I would have made
it worse trying to make it better you
know I don't know can we give a little
bit of credit to our editors too because
you know especially some of those uh you
know Josh Drisco who's been editing for
us since the original home movie
um Tim Roche your buddy from Rhode
Island Rhode Island who we had you know
auditioned to edit the show and just
absolutely crushed it right from the
beginning but those guys
you know they've also had you know their
their fingerprints are all over those um
those musical choices and uh and some of
the better edits you know some of the
some of the ways in which you know we
can kind of tie things together and and
make it all feel intentional
um you know I I gotta just you know I
mean I can remember a number of
instances in which we came back yeah I
mean often it's like hey Josh we want to
try something that feels like this but
then he's got to be the one to actually
sift through all that music and and try
and make it work and edit it edit the
music and stick it in the scenes you
know what I mean and uh you know those
guys just done such a terrific job I'll
tell you what I take that for granted
because I sometimes will have to work
with other editorial teams and and
post-production teams and you you
realize oh very quickly oh wow we have
some of the best editors and editorial
staff and produce post-production
producers in the business the role of
editor is such a huge I mean in a sense
they're directing their writing you know
they're they're you can completely
and this like this episode or the the
suburbs ones are like examples of like
completely Reinventing what the episode
is in the editing room
um the gang dines out you know so many
different versions of that so we landed
on that sort of like Italian music sort
of version of it and
there's I mean you can just drastically
change what it is and yeah there's a
there's a weird myth about
like I don't know like an auteur you
know like one and without a doubt they
they exist right like someone whose
influence is so great on all departments
that you know they're like a black hole
sucking everything towards their vision
and then out comes this amazing thing
but the reality is like the so much
collaboration involved from the costume
Department to the you know the casting
to the performers to the you know the
everything everything that certainly the
directors on her show and like uh
uh what else is there craft service well
no I think that's that's totally valid
is that the only place an auteur
actually exists is is if you're painting
something or [ __ ] drawing something
and it's just you and the medium now
that doesn't mean you don't have people
with exceptionally specific points of
view that everything gets gets yeah the
Coen brothers who are writing them the
Cohen Brothers aren't acting in their
move they're not acting in them and then
they're also uh you know they're being
lit by uh
um yeah
the best DPS in the world yeah Roger
tickets yes he's a living legend you
know and uh you know and then
photographs
oh Jerry photographs photographs is
gonna make it the Deacon of Photography
the Deacon is in the house you know um I
know just it's amazing didn't they take
they took stunts
like stunt people out of the Oscars they
took I mean they they kicked them to off
camera the DPS the people that are
actually capturing the images
[Laughter]
we have a whole episode about that yeah
well I'm going out to lunch with my
brain tonight yeah what's going on with
your Brands uh I had some beer I know I
thought I felt it I felt it you found me
a little girl that's what I'm saying no
no I mean I felt it last night or a
little puffy it was the it was the E.T
of it all around at 8 p.m let's have fun
tonight yeah Joe's kicking back it's
summertime
it's summertime yeah it was you're
playing golf no well I was but the this
week I've been working a bunch oh great
yeah writing and writing a lot of music
fun oh can we hear some of it no is this
for no share I'll share with you okay
and then I'll share with the public when
it's more refined excellent are you
gonna make an album you got you cutting
an album
uh I wanted to something uh like a movie
with a bunch of music in it I don't know
if I can pull it off but
if you guys weren't doing so many
goddamn things we could collaborate but
you guys are so [ __ ] busy well I mean
we collaborate quite a bit that's true
we do and I love it I love every second
of it um I do too I I like the idea of
putting a lot more energy into this
podcast I'm happy that we're here again
together all of us yeah reaching out and
touching to everybody's knees here which
I know you yeah absolutely yeah yeah but
you can't feel since the since the full
body replacement you can't feel the
knees anymore oh my God you were just
touching my hand I saw you do it I can't
feel that yeah can you only feel what
goes in and out of the mouth that's the
only thing I'm designed to feel now yes
yeah and it's not your only
hole
yes
are you thirsty you know you gotta be
third because I've taken so many sips of
water I want to give you a little water
you know I'm not lubricated you got it
I'm gonna get myself some more coffee
while you're watering Glenn
[Music]
you feel refreshed right oh yeah you're
right gosh I never I didn't realize I
needed that that was good thank you I
appreciate that you got it buddy um Rob
are you are you dressed in character
right now is that because I thought you
weren't going to set um
yeah that's why I Port said oh oh he's
joking
[Music]
you okay Glenn he got it you choked him
a little bit I mean you couldn't hear it
there Charlie
I didn't mean to choke you know I'm good
all right
uh
we've already covered the way I look
where are you not paying attention well
I know but I I but but you you you I
don't understand I'm just mixing it up I
couldn't watch it man it's very freeing
we're all going to have shaved heads
because as soon as I'm done uh you know
filming this movie I won't have to wear
this wig anymore and I can um I can
shave my head wow
um what else about this episode yeah
Glenn you're the host do you have any
questions for us now Rob uh the
inspiration behind your uh yours and uh
sweet D's uh costumes with the guardian
angels Curtis silhouette in New York
City yeah a group started by a man named
Curtis Silva I believe his name was and
the early 80s late 70s early 80s in New
York City I believe was a tough time and
I think that um the the general public
was taking matters into their own hands
and becoming their own police force and
uh the Guardian Angels were that force
and they would Patrol the Subways of New
York City late at night and just just
beat the [ __ ] out of people as far as I
did they bash people did they bash them
yeah yeah they bashed them up pretty
good I think they were just sort of a
threatening for course for good from
their vantage point and I don't know how
effective it was I do know that uh being
a vigilante has got some got some issues
just in its nature it's kind of yeah we
celebrate them Batman you know I guess
you could say all superheroes are
Vigilantes to some reckless these
superheroes really yeah Charlie talk to
us about your Serpico impersonation your
uh your your Al Pacino impersonation
that was that a was that a very
influential movie on you did you
remember like are you a big Pacino fan
yeah sure who doesn't love Pacino
um no I think that was just more of a
goof you know we were like uh we were
like all right what uh
you know probably breaking the story and
being like okay we have the cop car what
are people doing and
I didn't know how he came up with that I
was like okay now you're just turning
into Serpico I just thought it was I
think that was something that you just I
think that was something you wanted to
do yeah
the ponchos and the big hats and
you know like and like the just like the
yeah the choice of the Poncho really I
think has so much to do with it and just
being like sort of like what's what's
the opposite of dressing like a cop you
know what I mean how far in that
direction can we go and it's like a
poncho and a giant like I probably had
recently seen it within a year or two of
writing that episode and I was like yeah
well he's just doing a Serpico thing and
then I get to do a weird
it's always fun to like
be doing the impression and then having
to drop it you know like uh you're like
oh I'm walking and you're like now
you're doing Christopher Walken I'm like
no I'm not doing I'm walking I'm walking
away you know just those little things
like
but yeah I don't I don't remember I
don't think it would have worked as well
if you had not as the character
verbalize the fact that you wanted to do
a Serpico type thing yeah you know what
I mean to me that's what makes it funny
is that your character it's your
character being like Oh I can do a
Serpico type thing and then your
character going and getting the costume
and the fake beard yeah we'd already
sort of established that like my guy at
that point early on was like taking [ __ ]
too far we're all taking it too far and
I take it even like further into the
extremes right and that's sort of the
joke of that character and then so
uh
yeah I guess it was just like he wants
to do an Al Pacino impression and then I
don't know even and it's like the
writing out taking the Spin Doctors mix
and for the bear hey how about my jump
and that Freeze Frame at the end I
remember loving it at the time and I
loved it again last night you got so
high how did
I forgot some you got holy [ __ ]
man there's no way I think it was the
tucking of the knees I feel like I did I
think you can get that high again nah
man I feel like here's what I think
maybe happened I did one and you said
one of you guys said Hey try tucking
your knees up and it'll make you look
like you're even higher I think that's
what happened it's such a good pose man
the knees the arms that's great I'm
gonna say that it's the I it's the Magic
The Magic of Photography and a still
frame in the middle and at the at the
peak of flight and I'm gonna suggest
that you can still get up there and I
think we we should take I think I think
he could do it too yeah I think he could
do it again it'll explode upon Landing
yeah I think I'm gonna break like class
uh I think I could get in the air but
that was some height man that's a okay
here's what I'd like to propose to end
this episode I'd like to propose Charlie
and I going outside
um Glenn you also can join us of course
and we're going to uh take the the I'm
gonna take a video of you and uh and I'm
gonna have you jump into the air we're
gonna freeze frame it and at the very
end of this episode it's gonna go and
you're gonna be just as [ __ ] high as
you were in 2007.
better warm-up pal
wow better warm up
toward more Athletics all right let's
let's go let's do it
[Music]